if we erase white history it's over for
america look at they have this phony
idea of black history
woman history
mama history
homosexual history right right right
and mexican history everybody history
about white people yeah and if it wasn't
for white people these people wouldn't
even be here
and so we got to give thanks to the
white folks who created it and found it
and created in the greatest country
there's a pure research poll that said
it talked to black people hispanic
people asians and white people and it
measured their racial consciousness how
important they felt race was to their
identity and the irony because you would
expect according to the leftist
narrative white people they'd have the
highest racial identity they're white
supremacists
they had the lowest racial identity by a
long shot they were the least concerned
with race of anybody and yet it's being
pushed in our school crt you've got to
have a racial consciousness i mean where
where does this end